did you really break misha tate's arm
oh yeah oh yeah
that was that look like that elbow had
wrinkles on the wrong side
wow um that's crazy because you know
like
i mean i i gotta just tell you like a
huge
part of the reason why i'm so excited to
do this with you is because i'm such a
huge fan you in fact
got me into mma where before i just
didn't give a [ __ ] about it at all
i mean i used to work in uh
in a video store re-shelving the
rented vhs tapes and uh there was a
whole little section for
this was 1996 and ufc started in 93.
there was a whole section of ultimate
fighting and i tried to watch it at one
point and i was just like man all this
like laying on the grid because they
didn't have rounds
you know so like so the grappling
exchanges would
would be like really really long and i
found it boring
you know like of course now i'm like
such a crazy fan like i love all the
grappling
but uh but yeah i'm one of
millions of people who have become like
a die-hard
ufc fan like purely because of you
oh thank you i appreciate that i
actually
have like a very different grappling
background for most people because i
came from judo and the guys that you're
watching came from jiu jitsu where they
had
unlimited time on the ground and unless
you had a background in jiu jitsu you
wouldn't really know what you were
looking at
and so it's like what are these guys
doing it's boring it looks gay like
you know like all these people had these
preconceived notions about it
uh but i came from olympic judo which
you know with has very biased
officiating and so
like um they a lot of the times would
give me like one second even to work
from on the ground or two
you know i like had to constantly be
making progress
or they would make me stand up and so i
kind of always felt like i was fighting
against my opponent
and the referee you know so i kind of
had to make every match
into a fight in order to win and i had
to be able to
transition into an arm bar and finish
right away on the ground
because that was the most definite way
to win if you were choking somebody out
and they make you stand up
well that person just takes a deep
breath and they're fine if you're
pinning somebody and they make you stand
up well
they're absolutely fine but if you break
somebody's arm and they make you stand
up [ __ ] has a broken arm and if you
still lose after that then you're the
[ __ ]
like that's the kind of thing that my
mom would teach me as a kid so she would
be like
every single match everything that
you're doing every single time that you
hit the ground you are going straight
into breaking the arm as fast as you can
and that was kind of like how i was
drilled to think
from a very very young age like as young
as like 12 my mom was like okay
it's time for you to start doing our
bars and um
that was always the goal in every
exchange was it starts with
i get my hands on you we're going to get
to the ground at some point and as soon
as we hit the ground i should be trying
to break your arm immediately
so how many arms do you think you've
broken
i mean i don't know when i was like
younger when i was like
in my teens i would count that kind of
thing and feel cool and then after a
while
i'm like if you're still counting you're
an [ __ ] like i
don't know the moral of the story is
that like
it's only cool to break so many arms
that you lose count
i think if that's the kind of thing like
i realized i'm like that's not the kind
of thing to feel cool
for you know like i just kind of yeah i
like grew out of it
like you know call me petty
call me self-absorbed but if i had
broken multiple arms i would
like not only be counting but i would i
would feel
so [ __ ] cool that's so funny oh
you're not really breaking it so much as
like
a lot of times like you're dislocating
the joint hyper-extending
yeah like you can like you could feel it
like
popping and going out of the like the
socket like i used to relate it to like
tearing off turkey legs
you know you kind of like feel it it's
just like a weak joint in general it's
not like your shoulder that's like a
ball joint or like your hip it's a ball
joint like it has very limited range
and then past that range it takes very
little to push it past that
so i mean i've had my elbows dislocated
hundreds of times hundreds of times to
the point that like
like all of my ligaments here are super
loose like i've been arm barred when i
was younger and i was like
i'm invincible you know what i mean
they're like i'm just gonna let you pop
my arm out and then my arm's gonna be
like
malleable and i can slip out and then i
didn't realize that
even though you feel better in a few
weeks when you're 16 when you're in your
30s it comes back
and uh yeah it got to be like when i did
judo you would have like
grips to have like an inside grip and a
lot of times if someone had an inside
grip which is a dominant grip
you would try to bring your elbow over
and put their arm to the outside so
it was kind of like a chess game with
like gripping
and uh if my arm was slightly turned
like this well someone else did that
my arm would dislocate and i would have
to like pop my elbow back in all the
time
it would be dislocating all the time so
like to me like
just locating somebody's arm is not that
big of a deal
get ready this is going to be gnarly
pretty gnarly
kind of normal are we ready yeah
[Music]
what's up denver
women can paint their boobs and show
them on instagram
so i figure i should be able to paint my
dick and do whatever i want
make some noise for my brother
[Applause]
wait let me inspect for crabs this time
[Music]
when my buddies lit that stuff right
away i knew
i [ __ ] up
[Music]
i'm not doing this to hurt your dad
you're gonna hurt me you gonna piss me
off